Hey David, what would be your biggest criticism
of the left in America? This is a great question
and I addressed this a little bit on the Joe
Rogan program. I addressed this a little bit,
um, on the Monday show this week in talking
about these groups that have cropped up, like
for example, progressive's against David Packman
and Sam Cedar. Um, as many of you probably
know, I am against toxic identity politics,
but I don't think toxic identity politics
is as big of an issue on the left as some
think it is. When I see identity politics
used as a Cudgel, I call it out.
But mostly my view on identity politics is
we all should have a say and we should be
aware that people whose identity relates to
the issue at hand in some particular way might
have valuable insight, which we should listen
to. Wow. Hugely controversial. Right? But
that's my view. Um, when it comes to s j w
whatever, right? I mean, okay. There are people
who in any movement can take things too far,
but big picture SJWs are not the problem on
the left. Um, Antifa okay. To the extent Antifa
has been violent, I'm against it. Um, but
Antifa is very small and it is not representative
of the left's issues in any kind of big picture
sense. So what I do think is a problem on
the left that worries me is the two rigid
definition of what is acceptable within the
left. At this point in time.
I'm not going to Redo this entire commentary
because I did it on Monday, but there's a
really good article in politico by Joshua
sites called progressive's should read progressive
history so that they don't blow it this time.
When you go back to the progressive movement
of the early 19 hundreds when you go to the
new deal era of the thirties and you see the
huge successes that progressive's accomplished.
When you look at conservatives in the 70s
and eighties the conservative coalition of
the seventies and eighties they accomplish
stuff I don't like, but part of what they
did in progressive's in the early 19 hundreds
and in the 30s and conservatives in the seventies
and eighties is that they didn't define their
movement so narrowly that over a 10% disagreement
or a 20% disagreement, they cut people out
from even being allowed to work together where
they agree. So I'll give you some examples.
There is a disagreement on the left about
whether Nicolas Maduro is a good guy or not
a good guy, whether he's been good or bad
for Venezuela. I think that the evidence is
strikingly clear that Chavez Maduro have been
a disaster for Venezuela. But it doesn't really
matter if people disagree with me on that.
If we are United in the reality that the United
States should not intervene, the United States
involvement in regime change in Latin America
has been a disaster. That we need to keep
John Bolton away from Venezuela. We need to
keep Trump away from Venezuela. I, every time
I say this, the comments 99% are about how
dare I, I am a shill for the centrists CIA,
right? Or I don't even know what everything
is because of being Jewish. That that's why
I have, it's crazy. We all agree the US shouldn't
intervene in Venezuela. So let's focus on
that, right?
Uh, another example can be, I mean, I don't
know, there are so many of these, uh, when
it comes to the impeachment of Donald Trump,
increasingly the left is United, that there
have been impeachable offenses and that at
minimum an inquiry should start and very often
you will see a division start because some
people believe the Mueller report and others
on the left seem to believe the bar letter.
If either way you think aside from quote collusion
that there is impeachable activity that Donald
Trump has engaged in. Why are we arguing about
collusion at this point? It just doesn't make
any sense. Aside from the fact that there
were very few people on the left who actually
were expecting evidence that Trump personally
colluded with Putin. I mean, I don't know
who was expecting that. I said in April of
2018 that I wasn't. So the real concern for
me is that I don't want the progressive movement
to draw lines so narrowly about what is acceptable
v either via litmus tests or whatever, that
people who could get together and accomplish
80% of the agenda on which they agree are
going to instead ended up being enemies or
at least adversaries or at least talking past
each other and not working together because
of some 10 or 20% of the agenda on which they
disagree.
That's what I think is the biggest problem
with the left right now.